but will it be martini shaken not
stirred
you've put something in my drink
no I didn't yes you did no I did yes you
did yes you did yes you did yes you did
yes yep okay let's just get on with the
show fine right and this is so much
Jamie for completing our movie threesome
son honor and obviously we're super
excited about Spectre which is the theme
of today's show are you a
double-oh-seven fan big double-oh-seven
fan I love Casino Royale we do okay
brilliant movie all the way around
definitely talk about bond but one of
these I got to bring up I'm even looking
at like you do one of the best I
wouldn't I came to say impression of
Robin Williams you turn into him yeah
was Robin Williams a James Bond yeah
well hold on just a second
listen we'll get squared away of that
Romain later okay mister yes I love
James Bond what was it about James Bond
that you like oh I don't know all the
digits if you were to play James Bond
what would your version be like well I
know who my Bond girl would be I don't
know who talked to Jamie
maybe this will help there's gonna be
eventually a Robin winds biopic how many
times do hear Oh Jamie you should play
Robin Williams tonnes yeah yes is there
something you want to do yes would be
quite an honor and tribute one day but I
don't think that day's anywhere near
know you love vines you do a lot of
quick impressions right what would it be
like for you knowing an extended
impression or character it would be
quite the challenge but it'd be when I
would welcome because I'm an actor so
the ability and an opportunity to put
both together is just an awesome thought
well that's the thing that you bring up
here too because there are some people
who do like I do an Arnold impression
that's like hack which is gonna be your
favorite which is not gonna be afraid
Jamie isn't doing impressions he is
doing characters yeah he is becoming
those people's oh and Wilson by the way
mr. Wilson how wouldn't you play James
Bond I would just have a lot of wow
factor in there Ben Stiller he got a
constant
would you play a villain - oh yeah he
was shoot a lot of those blue steel
words like you see what I'm saying it's
like he becomes the person back to the
future - we just had I saw you did a
video of yourself being Marty and Doc
and George McFly could we could
appreciate hear that as well sound like
we got a jukebox here today yeah sure
yes it was you're a humble guy I'm
talking to you but you've gotta look and
go I'm good if I was to say mr. Williams
yeah out of all your favorite gadgets
what catch would you make oh I love all
the watches yes that's that's I feel
like that's how our minds would react
yeah it takes the back and forth to
smile and that takes work you feel like
all these characters or these people
have kind of bled into your personality
now kind of all the time my mom she
lights see me in something non
impression ya know acting in Trebek I
saw George Bush I'm like thanks mom
speaking of mr. Bush I believe that he
was paying attention to our weekly wager
oh so would you say that you're a
betting man I'd say if there are enough
stakes involved
no but seriously this is my favorite
part of the show where Y always you're
on the box top yeah so you'd like to see
me loose is what you're saying I didn't
say that last week if I'm not mistaken
y'all wagered on Scouts guide to the
zombie apocalypse yeah in front I'm
Sarah Dumont I'm standing right here
interesting you wagered 8.4 million
mm-hmm Tiffany wait hold on so I'm a
huge Lord of the Rings fan and I'm
pretty excited about what you're about
to say can you do it as Gandalf the box
on this title was 1.7 million what does
it matter it's not like anyone important
that I care about cares how I lost or
not Christian
I can't believe you lost just a damn
shame that's sex this week's punishment
comes from a YouTube viewer Brent Mason
who says make the loser of this loser
you know what he means Christian eat
Vegemite smiley face alright man well
real biochemical jazz you know this
stinks
yeah well that's just like your opinion
man bigger bite than that I think it's
gonna make 102 what do you think it's
gonna make Christian lady alright so
there is our weekly wager 102 and 97 I'm
probably gonna win again next week cuz
everyone loves Daniel Craig right who
chose this filth who chose it yes of
course yeah yeah here get out of here go
how about you write a script well if
you've got a punishment that you want to
submit for next week use the hashtag
loser should put it in the comments
below on YouTube on Twitter or Facebook
I don't think part of your loser should
was eat all the M&Ms but water
don't go water on this sort of kooky
Christian now gichan and Al and Dan and
I am super excited to see Spectre I am a
huge James Bond fan I cannot wait now
Jamie there's rumors here that Daniel
Craig's gonna step down there have been
six actors that have played James Bond
out of all the impressions that you do
I'd love to see some of those guys how
old their bond be like there's Sparrow
Captain Jack
bored Harrison Ford
Walken Christopher Walken who was
actually a Bond villain that's true I
feel like just from the Lincoln
commercials alone Matthew McConaughey is
trying to put his name into the mix yeah
that's um that's actually a fact
Matthews I've been working on him for a
while now and nothing it's safe to say
he's on his way in fact there he is up
there at the top number seven and
there's a few movies that are you know
they have their titles I'm already oh my
god then I'm gonna be in one of those is
how to kill a spy in ten days guns and
confused was that final one how to fight
Murph how to find Mert and and actually
there's a fourth in the mix the man with
the golden Lincoln everybody has a
favorite or two so why don't we rank
them okay we think is our best bond and
we're ranking them from double-oh-seven
is the best yeah down to double it one I
feel bad for whoever ends up there I'll
go first and please everyone yeah you go
buddy that's for you poor George I think
it's only fair to go number two give it
to the guests I'm putting Dalton at
three he's Brosnan going at double O
four I'm gonna put Pierce at double O
five and Connor oh how dare you have
four well are we leaving we're leaving
McConaughey double-oh-seven
I've got it oh so McConaughey gets five
in six days
oh and four I'm gonna bring some order
to this point hey get meshed all those
three that's your list basically
Trevelyan double six
no wait well 600 you're gonna go agree
with that now okay we have a double O
one George Lazenby number two Roger mole
number three Timothy Dalton
madam akane is double o4 and then number
five
Pierce prawns and of course Daniel Craig
can't do him but he's awesome and
double-oh-seven
Sean Connery goes first
let them tell us who they think it
should be in the comments Thank You
Jamie Kosta for joining us if you guys
want to follow this funny man on social
media follow him at Jamie Kosta but on
Twitter it's at Kosta James that's right
and make sure you download the Fandango
movie clips app on your smartphones and
join us next week on don't forget to
click subscribe over there check out
more videos right over there
okay now